I'm all the way over drought
outrageous acts of science
UK TV show today's episode featured our
GoPro money canon video so the company
sent us the cut of the episode and also
we are seeing comments on our video
that's saying that they saw the episode
so you can get superval 6 a.m. now
Saturday July 1st Wendy and I are going
to Minnesota for the fourth of July
briefly for the airport in an hour and a
half we've impact put the camera down
for this is oh all right we made it I
left my hat back on the plane I'm gonna
go see if I can reclaim it sweet I
pulled everything out I left my hat when
he left her phone
[Music]
only kids on my route to go ahead and
tell Wendy though that we didn't
actually find it I'll say yeah they
searched the whole plane couldn't find
it no one didn't know where it was
come on No get in here No right here
think we got everything now vanilla
whatever whatever you're hella bean
whatever you're trying to sell to me
stop selling because I'm buying it good
you just took you just took two out of
the six cookies uh-huh
it's supposed to one for everyone you
just took two mmm yes these are my
favorite dude
Meghan Meghan take one they're so good
yeah really good I love it mmm
these automatically grab to see now for
social one for Sam Rico and Peter he
took two I didn't offer you two men you
all to open the whole thing and you
never offered a we made it to the lake
house this is my cousin Annan Rob's lake
house and it's on balsam lake the
beautiful spot it just redid everything
so it's dirty and gross
[Music]
you guys remember my brothers right
Hey
[Music]
dad hello darkness my old friend I've
come to talk Wendy yes honey we made it
it's the fourth of July we are here at
the start of the race the marine four
mile how do you feel that your
preparation is gone leading up to this
event preparations been great the black
bouillabaisse be worse pleased to be
Taco Bell no water lots of beer Carlos
coming up with two of the good one three
of you have to cook last - OH - the good
one I think like well looks like
chocolate and caramel yeah we won't
happen
did Nick did you try it I did I wasn't
moving like a gingerbread caramel Oh am
I give it to someone who hasn't tried
that I think everyone here you set the P
- man enough if you click on try the
other one hmm okay yesterday yes Jenna
thanks Donna I know you all know
Virendra video to you a thank you more
I'm gonna I'm gonna
back of the pack club we just want to
make sure no one gets left behind you
know at a blistering pace now just Pat's
one mile but we're not laughs it gets
all downhill so I think we're going to
make it on the under an hour
[Music]
I
we're at 46 23 that's the three mile
marker right there Wendy one mile to go
are you going to make it in under an
hour
but we got a hustle we're going to make
it under an hour well now I think we're
in last
the finish is right down there 5845 yep
not to erupt and our moments can finish
at the end
[Music]
I'm done with the race how was the race
no more a I'm not camera-ready by any
means but feel free to skip get a sneak
peek in here clip there is there is no
titty
we're back here at MSP I've had a great
trip we did all the things we needed to
do let's go back to LA what do you need
that design so it's always okay to be
camera
well we caught a time get a second
channel to stick in touch me
so when the tail gets down from behind
the camera the extra is sitting food
where's lamby that I take that which
means it's always facing Wow TV guys
well hell we call them I'm expecting
like actual commentary in such a Anika
gets your logs on your beard her
parachute all that I go yeah from
alright and I receive that everyone act
up again some zoo cannot assume on it
yeah
[Music]